it's time for drew's news your good news
umbrella and a rainy news storm and with
me at the desk is my cozy cup of soup on
a rainy day rossignol i'ma warm you up
bye everybody
okay rock your story i have a story you
are not going to believe newsweek
reports a woman on reddit confessed that
she
swapped her wife's mean cat
for a different cat
nice cat and to this day her wife has no
idea
[Applause]
i couldn't believe this she claimed it
happened back when they were dating uh
her then girlfriend was out of town and
she went over to feed her black cat and
the cat like scratch her to smithereens
so
so she went to the shelter she got a
nicer black cat
found a home for the other black cat and
now six years later
the wife has no idea
i think this is totally naughty
and i'm not really big on lies in
relationships yeah and this one feels
like a pretty big one yeah
but it's like meet the parents but
nobody ever finds out jinxy cat isn't
like the painted tail rescue like how
did you not know that wasn't your cat if
i have three chihuahuas if you were a
place want to be like cute chihuahua
where's mine
[Applause]
well
we're a pair of hopeless romantics at
this desk and we like to keep our
antennas up for fun new ways to find
love
today we've got a modern take on the old
school personal ad the new york times
reports hot singles is a weekly email
newsletter that drops a new hottie in
your inbox every week
it's put together by rhonda sakala and
you can subscribe for free you'll meet
eligible singles like plant-based
princess looking for a romaine tick
partner yes you did
let us applaud for this city bike boy
looking for a city bike bay to take him
for a ride
okay
each ad includes a photo and a q a to
get to know your hottie a little better
it's funny because hot singles gives me
like sort of young trendy like sexy
vibes and i feel like this is a little
bit more
old world a little more patient a little
more thoughtful this is not the boom
yeah so hot singles the like the name
doesn't kind of measure up to the sort
of old worldness of being patient
waiting weekly responding in a letter
personal ads yeah can i ask you some
questions that you could answer in this
hot singles ad sure okay um what are you
looking for in a partner
someone who can be nice every day
oh that's good
and i wish these things for everybody
yeah you know i have to say if i wasn't
engaged and you know if straight
straight
i mean those are a couple big hurdles
but we could have really get it off
really something could have happened
here as they say in real estate there's
always gonna be something
okay here's the most interesting
question oh what is your most toxic
trait oh like what's the red flag of you
like i really am hard on myself like
toxically so the inner dialogue is
corrosive i'm like you are so good to
other people and then you get to
yourself and it's just like
no no room for error can i challenge you
to something
next time you're spiraling on yourself
will you just say to you drew i'm going
to treat you
as well as you treat ross because you
are so good to me you are you're so kind
and you're so loving and you're so sweet
so if you wouldn't say it to me don't
say it to your mom
that's a good challenge take it and i
have to tell you ross if anyone ever
messed with rossie
oh look at that face oh
i will take you down
okay so reddit is really good for cat
confessions
but it turns out
it's also good for planning a worm party
yeah what now yes romper.com reports
that one mom wrote in to a reddit post
title daughter insists on wormed themed
birthday okay
and she got flooded with suggestions on
how to make her whimsical worm party of
her five-year-old's dreams people shared
dirt cake ideas with little gummy worms
inside of them yeah and we did our own
digging
and found out worm dogs those are like
hot dogs that look like you're eating
little worms oh
okay we also found worm pizza we're in
dirt cups for dessert uh-huh um like
really it's just chocolate yes yeah it's
just like ground up like
cookies
yeah and then putting in the middle
putin
um oh and look we even found you some
worm balloons
cute with a little googly eyes whoa
hi
[Applause]
hi hi
hi
cute
well from worms to workplace this is
interesting a new survey finds that the
highest performing teams at the office
are the teams who are having the most
fun
insider reports a survey of one thousand
workers found the most productive teams
who are also most likely to be joking
around sharing gifts and emojis swearing
together oh uh-huh i would be
i if swearing led to anything i would
excel at it yes you would
but you're a winner
you do
i love swearing i love it so much well
they also say not just swearing but
gossiping makes you more productive too
um and for bosses the survey found that
the number one thing you can do if
you're a boss to improve performance is
to give credit and recognize hard work
there's nothing bad that comes out of
telling people that they're doing a good
job yeah
but
i do
love that people who swear and have fun
this is my best news ever and then on
the gossip front and information and pop
culture and all exciting tidbits well
guess what michelle turner my amazing
friend from entertainment tonight she's
gonna come out here right after the
break and tell us
[Music]
you